[Musique]
bonjour françois bayrou merci de
m'accueillir ici à pau on est au palais
beaumont qui est une sorte de palais des
congrès de la ville
c'est une ville dont vous êtes bien sûr
le maire le maire depuis 2014 et ce qui
m'a frappé c'est que je vous ai proposé
qu'on réalise cette émission soit à
paris soit ici à pau et vous avez
insisté pour que ça se fasse à pau et
j'ai senti qu'ils avaient presque chez
vous le sentiment qu'ici vous seriez
davantage libre pour pouvoir dire ce que
vous pensez pour pouvoir vous exprimer
est-ce qu'il ya le bayrou de paris et le
baril le barreau de pau comme sûrs et le
rat des villes et le rat des champs
mais bon c'est pas tout à fait les
champs c'est une ville qui est la
capitale d'une région historique
historiquement important c'est bien ton
nom soit resserrée celui de larry et
celui d'ailleurs j'ai l'impression
d'être le même partout mais probablement
vous le dites c'est plus libres ici
parce qu'il ya moins votre pression fin
la pression des médias le caméra les et
puis c'est ici que je suis n'est que
j'ai grandi que ma famille s'est formé
et a grandi et que j'ai conquis tous mes
mandats de représentation politique sans
exception et puis c'est une ville dont
je crois pouvoir dire que nous avons
changé le visage en quelques années
et donc oui je suis plus à ma place de
responsable que dans les débats
politiques que que j'accepte que je que
j'assume que vous ne fuyez pas que je ne
fus pas en rien parce que j'ai toujours
pensé que être citoyen c'est être
citoyen enracinée et citoyens dans le
débat le plus large possible mais à voir
ce lien justement
nouveau mot un peu à la mode c'est le
mot de territoire on va y revenir
largement je disais qu'on aurait pu le
faire à paris parce que vous êtes aussi
désormais haut commissaire au plan qui a
d'ailleurs des bureaux à paris
vous êtes vous avez été ministre vous
êtes bien sûr mêlée à la politique à la
vie politique depuis des années vous le
disiez du point de vue de l'élu mais
aussi ministre de l'éducation éphémère
ministre de la justice
vous avez ouvrait à l'arrivée d'
emmanuel macron au pouvoir vous en avez
et est même l'un des rouages avec la
complicité la légitimité je dirais que
vous lui avoir apporté est votre regard
sur la france et sur lui à un an des
prochaines élections
il est particulièrement attendu je vais
être assez directe est ce que vous
n'êtes pas un peu déçu quand même non
non si je l'étais je vous le dirai pas
du tout je c'est un homme très jeune
naturellement que je ne connaissais pas
avant de le soutenir et pas une seule
fois dans ces quatre années
je n'ai eu le sentiment de m'être trompé
mais souvent jamais il m'est souvent
arrivé de penser que naturellement je
lui ai dit d'ailleurs le premier jour
sous vos caméras
il lui manquait les années d'expérience
qui sont très utiles quand on assume une
fonction aussi impressionnante que celle
là mais son élection il ya toujours des
raisons aux choses l'élection d'un homme
si jeune c'était aussi que le pays avait
besoin d'un renouveau alors évidemment
comme vous savez il a été frappé par des
tsunamis successifs comme probablement
rarement des présidents avant lui ont
été frappés il en a mûri il à
métaboliser comme on dit en médecine
c'est à dire
intégré il s'en ait changé les grands
événements du monde et les grands
glissement de la société dans lesquelles
nous sommes mais jamais une seule fois
je n'ai été déçus ou où vous savez c'est
sentiment de gêne que parfois on éprouve
y compris à l'égard de ses propres amis
en disant qu'ils sont pas exactement ce
qu'on voudrait lui jamais pour moi en
tout cas sur le plan de l'expérience on
va y revenir avec notamment sa façon à
lui de retourner aujourd'hui sur le
terrain comme il l'a refait cette
semaine mais au fond c'était peut-être
cette alliance entre votre expérience
avoue sa jeunesse à lui dont vous étiez
dit que cette alchimie allait lui
permettre quand je vous dis est-ce que
vous n'êtes pas déçu il ya évidemment
pour la france c'est en cela vous m'avez
répondu mais aussi pour vous sert que
finalement on se dit bon est-ce qui vous
a pas un peu eu quoi qu'est ce qu'est ce
que vous en avez retiré notamment sur
des batailles qui sont les vôtres équipe
très cher je pense notamment aux
questions démocratiques je pense à la à
la banque de la démocratie qui devait
faire vivre la démocratie autrement je
pense à la proportionnelle évidemment
alors si vous voulez me dire que j'ai de
bonnes idées
je serais d'accord c'est content de
pouvoir le dire de vous même dont il
avait saisi sept ans c'est vous savez
bien que ce sont des sujets dans
lesquels je suis engagée depuis très
longtemps
est ce que la démocratie française
marche bien non elle ne marche pas aussi
bien qu'elle pourrait marcher ou en tout
cas elle est frappée de deux handicaps
et de faiblesses qu'on pourrait
supprimer peut-être on aura l'occasion
d'en parler
vous en avez cité 2 le financement de la
vie politique ça ça ne va pas parce
qu'évidemment quand vous passez par des
banques privées
évidemment il n'y a pas la même
objectivité la même équité qu'on devrait
trouver
en respectant la vie politique et la
démocratie comme elle est et puis est-ce
que la représentation des français juste
elle est injuste et je suis absolument
certain à titre personnel que emmanuel
macron le sait c'est pour ça que j'ai
dis toujours à vos interviews que moi je
considérais que cette bataille n'était
pas perdu même si la plupart des
responsables politiques s'en accommode -
pas je pense que la bataille
elle peut être livré et gagné la
bataille n'est pas perdue parce que vous
avez réussi à le convaincre
messi alors même qu'il est convaincu il
ne le fait pas qu'est ce qui bloque
il bloque quelque chose que on apprend
que au contact du pouvoir c'est qu'on a
beau avoir tous les pouvoirs que la
constitution donne un chef d'état
français ont de plus gouverner que si on
arrive à convaincre l'opinion et le
système politique
or le plus difficile à convaincre sur le
sujet dont nous parlons c'est le système
politique à ceux qui ont tout intérêt à
ne pas le partager
on a intérêt à ce que rien ne change sur
la question des élections vous l'avez
tout de suite dit et c'est ce qui
légitime vraiment tout votre démarche
c'est que vous avez toujours été puisée
auprès des électeurs ici à pau votre
légitimité
emmanuel macron on le sent bien il n'y a
pas eu ce socle là il est arrivé
directement par le haut en quelque sorte
il retourne du coup régulièrement faire
ce qu'il appelle des tours de france
il a repris son bâton de pèlerin c'est
sa propre expression
en allant dans le dans le lot cette
semaine il a d'autant plus besoin de ces
moments là alors
d'une part il n'est pas l'homme qu'on
croit vous avez peut-être lu il ya
grant interview dans un journal qui
s'appelle zadig est tout à fait
interview très original pour un
président de la république française
parce qu'il parle de ses racines
profondes et une partie de ses racines
sont ici dans les pyrénées que vous
apercevez présence espérée derrière la
barre des 10 en voyez bbu si vous
regardez et donc c'est là c'est chez lui
chez sa grand-mère et la france qu'il
raconte c'est une france qui passe le le
la barrière des générations parce que
c'est une france qui ressemble en partie
à ce que les instituteurs de des
décennies précédentes transmettait
puisque sa grand mère était institutrice
et principal de collège et qu'elle lui a
transmis quelque chose qui est assez
rare chez les présidents successifs
françois mitterrand avait ça c'est ce
que j'allais vous dire c'est le sens de
la géographie et on le voit très bien
dans cette interview et on le voit très
bien quand on parle avec lui j'ai la
chance de parler assez soit signé à lui
parler très régulièrement
oui oui vous n'avez jamais il n'y a
jamais eu de moment où vous êtes fâchés
j'avoue être découragés ou classifie
jamais jamais je d'abord parce que c'est
pas mon tempérament je fais pas les
choses par hasard je fais pas les choses
à moitié je ne change pas d'avis tous
les quatre matins
certains diront pas assez et donc je je
je sais ce que je fais quand je fais un
choix et en général je me tiens mais je
n'en n'ai jamais eu la tentation est ce
que ça veut pas dire quand même un peu
avec vous il a cette relation très
directe qui passe je dirais presque
comme au dessus de de cette forteresse
dans laquelle il est un peu enfermé
je pense pas à la forteresse au sens le
palais comme on dit mais
finalement c'est un homme qui est arrivé
à ces seules qui avait pas des
compagnons fidèles qui serait là pour
lui pour le bousculer pour lui dire bah
là ça va pas est ce que par exemple je
sais que le premier tour de france en
quelque sorte grand débat vous faisiez
partie de ceux qui l'y avaient
encouragée qu'il avait dit qu'il faut
aller parler avec les français mais oui
c'est français il n'est pas à distance
de bave comme on dit lorsque le
président de la république a décidé le
grand débat il y avait très très très
peu de gens qui l'y encourageaient il y
avait même un certain nombre de gens qui
l'en décourager
il en décourager parce que c'était une
prise de risque
or la manière dont les pouvoirs sont
organisées
c'est qu'ils redoutent le risque or le
risque c'est la vie et s'il ya une chose
dont elle m'a crombez convaincu
profondément convaincu c'est qu'il faut
prendre des risques mais à quoi ça a
servi un vrai résister à des tsunamis
auquel le beaucoup auraient cédé et à
forger une vision ou à renforcer une
vision et regarder ses cahiers de
doléances des français ce sont après le
grand mouvement des gilets jaunes ont
été dans les mairies dans les halls des
mairies pour remplir des cahiers a quand
même l'impression qu'ils sont installés
tiroirs non non pas alors il y en avait
beaucoup et je sais très bien que quand
on fait des consultations
parfois on est débordé par le nombre et
et qu'on n'a pas l'étude scrupuleuse
qu'on pourrait ou devrait avoir dans ce
début de tour de france emmanuel macron
dit avoir été frappé par la différence
entre le rapport qu'il avec les français
il ya deux ans quand il a été dans les
territoires dont il parlait surtout
pouvoir d'achat et cette fois ci où on
lui parle davantage sécurité je voudrais
qu'on les écoute
nous sommes dans une société qui est
plus en plus violentes et sarre sortait
beaucoup aussi des débats
et la violence que nous avons dans la
société elle n'est pas séparable aussi
des changements
j'ai plusieurs fois dit un peu
anthropologique que nous vivons il
ajoute nous vivons dans une nation qui a
un sentiment d'insécurité est ce qu'il y
a un sentiment d'insécurité oui jour
après jour
vous avez des agressions et des drames
alors c'est chaque fois une un agresseur
avec des victimes parfois des victimes
qui meurent qui sont blessés mais quand
ça se réédite tous les jours quand ça se
représente tous les jours oui ça crée un
sentiment de on peut pas supporter ça on
peut pas supporter de vivre comme ça je
reprends cette formule emmanuel macron
quand il dit il ya un sentiment
d'insécurité
ça fait quand même écho à la campagne de
2002 lionel jospin qui tout d'un coup
s'était retrouvé face à une france qui
avait un sentiment d'insécurité que
peut-être contrairement emmanuel macron
ils n'avaient pas décelé en tout cas pas
un an avant avant l'élection vous étiez
candidat en 2002 est ce que vous n'avez
pas peur que justement sur ces questions
de sécurité emmanuel macron se casse un
peu les dents appelé de malherbe
je n'ai peur de rien ce je pense que la
peur n'est pas une attitude politique
n'est pas un centime en politique
j'aurais pu dire autrement
est ce que est ce que vous ne craignez
pas pour emmanuel macron et c'est
peut-être le moment de le lui dire que
sur les questions de sécurité
il faut se réveiller quoi je je sais que
c'est pour lui une préoccupation de
chaque instant
je sais qu'il est profondément préoccupé
par l'organisation de l'état sur ces
sujets je sais qu'il souffre de la
difficulté de 2,2 relations entre le
haut et le bas y compris sur les
problèmes de sécurité
le jeu s'est calé son sentiment sur
ce que ressentent les policiers par
exemple sentiment d'être c'est souvent
incompris de difficultés de relations
avec la justice
on est dans le constat non mais quand
est ce que quand est ce que ça bouge
quand est-ce que ça quand est ce que ça
change
écoutez franchement le les les efforts
qui ont été faits pour que sur le
terrain il y ait une espèce de
réarmement l'état des commissariats
c'est des choses concrètes le le fait
qu' on n'est plus maître de la police de
sécurité du quotidien comme on dit y
compris chez nous le fait que quand on
repère un quartier sensible en mette
plus de moyens sur ce quartier sensible
c'est vrai en sécurité c'est vrai pour
l'école on a fait la même chose pour
l'une et pour l'autre donc le il n'est
pas vrai qu'il ne se passe rien vous
fait penser à ce qui s'est passé cette
semaine et qui est vraiment à la croisée
des deux choses que vous dites sécurité
et éducation à rennes une école qui est
au milieu d'un quartier avec des dealers
et en fait ils utiles utilisent depuis
des années mais en fait rien de ce fait
les dealers installe tranquillement leur
petit commerce aux portes de l'école
c'est ce qu'on finit par décider les
professeurs et la mairie et ben de
mettre des grandes bâches sur les
grilles de l'école parce qu'en fait
comme ils n'arrivent pas à éradiquer la
violence les trafics est bien la seule
chose qu'ils peuvent faire c'est au
moins que les élèves ne le voit plus
d'eau qu'ils ont caché et mis ces bâches
est-ce que c'est pas le symbole de ce
qui se passe en france aujourd'hui c'est
à dire qu'en fait on on n'y arrive pas
et donc au fond on à l'éducation et
l'insécurité qui sont confrontées l'une
à l'autre et on se contente de mettre
des bâches c'est votre métier et donc il
est normal que vous l'exercez en mettant
en exergue mais honnêtement si vous
faites le tour du pays
combien d'écoles ont des basses pour
séparer c'est trop c'est une de trop et
c'est pas acceptable et 6
la police nationale la police municipale
je ne sais pas c'est une police
municipale à rennes mais on a en tout
cas dans une ville comme la mienne mis
en place un réseau de vidéosurveillance
suffisamment fournis pour que ça rende
absolument impossible ça c'est si cette
affaire se passait à pau y aurait dans
la demi journée
l'installation de caméras de
surveillance qui rendrait dont les
images serait répercutée immédiatement à
notre centre de sécurité urbaine c'est à
dire la police municipale et à la police
nationale et on aurait des patrouilles
en or est ce qu'il faut ce lorsqu'un
fait se reproduit tous les jours comme
ça il est inacceptable qu'on soit
désarmé et connaît les bras ballants je
serai candidat modéré gionale c'est dans
quinze jours françois bayrou ont parlé
des territoires on a quand même
l'impression qu'à chaque fois c'est
aussi là que vous refusez la légitimité
cette légitimité à aucun moment ni ans
des municipales ni des régionales à
venir en marche n'aura vraiment réussir
à creuser son sillon
c'est très long de construire un parti
voulait s'excuser à chaque fois on vous
trouvez toujours ah non j'ai souvent
vous avez dit que vous étiez pas déçu
prix d'avenches pas tant mieux et
j'arrive bien je le soutiens aujourd'hui
parce que je pars ce que je vois
l'orientation et que je crois que
l'orientation est bonne et que la double
intuition de ce que nous avons à
reconstruire un pays par par la
reconquête par des créations par
l'esprit d'entreprise
elle est juste et que ça ne se fera que
si l'état change
dans un cadre européen qui acceptera de
se défendre
au lieu d'être constamment en train de
subir si vous prenez ces 3
certitude là est la quatrième qu'on a
besoin d'être défendus pas seulement
sécurité intérieure mais aussi dans les
drames du monde extérieur avec une
défense nationale qui qui tienne est pas
là tout ça c'est juste
donc je dis quand c'est juste je veux
être en soutien
comme vous voyez la montée du
rassemblement national et notamment avec
plusieurs régions qui en tout cas
d'après les sondages d'opinion sont
gagnables pour le rassemblement national
comment est-ce que vous expliquer ce
phénomène est ce qu'il ya un moyen de
lutter pour pour vous pour emmanuel
mâcon oui le c'est pas un moyen de lutte
et il n'y a qu'une voie de lutter je
vais vous dire quelque chose qui peut
être très différent de ce que beaucoup
de responsables politiques vous disent
c'est pas en faisant du rassemblement
national l'épouvantail universel que des
batailles comme celle là se gagne pas
c'est ça vit dans l'obsession de marine
le pen ou de sa famille ou deux pas du
tout comme ça qu'on construit un pays
ont construit un pays d'en haut
contraire une envie une adhésion une
part dont on a quand même un peu
l'impression que en marche
ils sont dans l'obsession du racing ne
vous parle pas d'eux un parti politique
ou d'un autre ou d'une majorité ou d'une
autre je parle du pays je parle des
français et des responsables politiques
ou de ceux qui aspirent à l'être ou qui
le sont je ne suis pas partisan de
l'obsession du front national le
meilleur moyen de se battre c'est de
porter un style et un projet attractif
et le stylet pour moi aussi à l'énergie
le la volonté l'optimisme le parfois la
capacité de d'être remplie d'inquiétude
et de soucis et parfois la capacité de
sourire ou de rire d'être avec les
français comme sont dans leur vie
cette manière de vivre positive est plus
importante pour gagner les batailles que
de passer son temps dans l'obsession
de la crainte la peur mais il ya aussi
j'aimerais de ce côté il faut que les
choses soient très claires et dit
en 2002 jacques chirac fera face à la
main et le pen vous même comme d'autres
n'hésitez pas et dit il faut faire front
quand même ce front républicain c'est
une expression qu'on n'entend quasiment
plus oui ben vous voyez bien chacun
aujourd'hui chacun joue sa carte
ouais il faut dire les choses comme
elles sont chacun considère que ma foi
les grands combats doivent passer après
les intérêts de parti je crois qu'ils se
trompent
mais encore une fois je je ne je ne veux
pas me placer dans cette seule obsession
je voyais et on a en trente ans on a
laisser s'effondrer l'appareil productif
du pays
ben faut le reconstruire
et ça ne se fera pas en ayant peur du
front national ça se fera en portant des
décisions des orientations des méthodes
qui ont été oubliés depuis 30 ans et qui
doivent être reprises et vous avez
justement remis au goût du jour la
planification vous parlais tout à
l'heure la question de l'efficacité
en voilà en tout cas à vos yeux un des
outils vous êtes donc haut commissaire
au plan depuis le mois de septembre
dernier est l'une de vos toutes
premières notes au fond en tout cas
celle qui a fait le plus de bruit
c'est l'idée d'un pacte national je vous
cite un pacte national pour la
démographie afin de sauver le modèle
social français et ça passe par deux
biais fin 2 2 voies avoir plus d'enfants
relancer la natalité française et
accueillir davantage de personnes qui
l'unira je n'ai jamais écrit cela alors
écrit simplement il faut un équilibre
naturel ment et il faut que y ait une
harmonie dans le pays qu'ils fassent
bien dit qu'il fallait sauver le modèle
louisiane aux français avec leur
humanité nationale mais je n'ai jamais
pensé
diddy ni soutenu je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi que l'immigration était une
réponse à ça l'immigration c'est une
réalité trop souvent parce que nous
n'avons pas chez nous
la volonté de prendre un certain nombre
d'emplois absolument nécessaire et que
on refuse d'assumer dans le tissu de la
société française comme elle est les
allemands ont dû faire la même chose ils
sont allés chercher en un seul coup un
million de personnes en une seule année
et c'est parce que je souhaite pour chez
nous pourquoi
c'était pas forcément une bonne chose
bah je pense que le patronat allemand
avait exigé qu'ils aient un tel apport
de population
quand c'est la tête ce lien quand c'est
en une seule fois
à la limite on peut estimer que la
coagulation se fait ou que le l'osmose
se fait mais c'est pas mon point de vue
mon point de vue est que naturellement
il ya une immigration et qu' il faut la
prendre en compte et réussir son
intégration et qu'il continuera à y en
avoir ce qu'ils vous disent que on va
passer à l'immigration zéro pour moi se
trompent parce que si vous regardez
l'état du monde et l'équilibré du monde
alors vous apercevrez que il ya des
continents entiers qui se développent du
point de vue de la population à vitesse
grand v
ça c'est illusoire de penser que on
pourrait mettre pause l'immigration
comme certains candidats le promettre
oui ils le promettent mais ne feront pas
il y en a déjà qui ont promis sa part
fait ils n'ont pas fait ce qu'il faut
obtenir c'est une immigration maîtrisée
réguler une immigration une immigration
dont on reprend le contrôle qu'on ne
subit pas qu'une et qui n'est pas une
immigration dans lesquelles nous sommes
nous devant laquelle nous sommes
désarmés
raison pour laquelle raison
supplémentaire pour laquelle il faut
avoir un équilibre des populations si
vous avez une population qui fléchit du
point de vue démographique alors le
monde qui vous entoure et qui lui est en
progression
je pense à l'afrique par exemple
naturellement le jeu des vases
communicants jouera est ce la caricature
et puisque vous en effet alors peut-être
que moi même je me suis trompé mais
c'est vrai que quand on a lu les
rapports de votre preuve de cette note
on a eu l'impression que les deux
réponses sur un pied d'égalité c'était
natalité il migre a dit se trouve que ce
n'est pas vrai et que si on avait pris
la peine de lire cette note comme
j'assume toujours ce que je dis on
aurait vu que c'était pas vrai mais vous
savez ce que c'est votre métier
la première dépêche commande tout le
reste un mot sur la question du pacte
des générations qui est une des choses
aussi sur lesquels vous insistez vous
dit notamment qu'il est nécessaire qu'il
que ça passe le modèle français par une
solidarité entre les générations
cette semaine emmanuel macron à a laissé
entendre que la réforme des retraites
serait abandonnée en tout cas que ça
n'était pas le moment
est-ce que de ce point de vue là vous
vous dites c'est une bonne chose
c'était pas le moment je ne suis pas sûr
que le moment d'une campagne électorale
soit le bon moment pour traiter de la
contrôler entre la dernière campagne
électorale et celle ci n'a pas eu
vraiment le moment pour savoir que ce
soir bah si l'on essayait peut-être pas
quand il aurait fallu ceci et autres est
autre chose
la réforme des retraites est inéluctable
ce que défend cette note c'est que le
contrat social français là précisément
la colonne vertébrale de la formation du
pays de la nation
pourquoi est-ce qu'on se sent du même
pays ça a plusieurs raisons la langue en
est une
le l'état en est une et le contrat
social nous sommes solidaires on est un
des seuls pays à avoir choisi des
retraites par répartition que ça veut
dire est pas répartition c'est que
chacun n'acquiert pas des droits au fur
et à mesure de la vie ce sont les actifs
qu'ils paient au jour le jour au mois le
mois pour payer avec ce grand risque qui
est que ce risque de la pyramide des
âges c'est la pyramide des âges
s'effondrent les retraites
s'effondreront la vie s'allongeant
le fait qu'on travaille moins d'années
tout ça met en péril les remises à
l'heure et si je vous écoute cette
réforme des retraites elle est
absolument nécessaire elle ne sera donc
pas fait
on l'a bien compris alors ce quinquennat
elle sera au coeur de la campagne
présidentielle
et chacun viendra et dira si oui ou non
il est déterminé à assumer cette réforme
pour une seule raison c'est que les
pensions continuent à être payés parce
que si on va dans le sens de des bras
ballants et de se désintéresser du sujet
alors un jour ce sont les pensions qui
seront en question est celle un jour
peut-être prochain ce sont les pensions
sont en question et la la la réforme des
retraites alors été mené à son terme
s'il n'y avait pas eu d'épidémie que
vous avez vécu comme nous l'avons vécu
et qui a en effet gilet jaune épidémie
c'était quand même deux grosses vagues
de tsunami épidémie on est pour rien
tout le monde l'a subie gilet jaune
pardon mais ça fait aussi partie d'une
forme de réponse à l'élection des
manuels maintenant ça fait partie d'une
réponse à 30 années de rupture entre la
base de la société
ceux qui travaillent ceux qui sont au
chômage ceux qui sont à la retraite et
le prétendu sommet l'état duo qui
regardent comme ça d'un air un peu
condescendant la base du pays
est ce à ce que les gilet jaune on dit
ou en tout cas en manifester ce qu'ils
ont transmis c'est ça c'est le
l'insupportable situation de ceux qui
font vivre le pays et qui ont le
sentiment qu'ils sont pas pris en compte
mais est-ce que c'est pas un peu facile
d'arriver au bout du quinquennat en
disant bon on n'a pas pu réformer mais
on n'y était pour rien donc il faut
qu'on recommence
moi je dirais pas ça je pense que que
beaucoup beaucoup de choses ont été
faites et tout le monde s'en rend compte
regardez-le efforts qu'on a faits
précisément en phase de l'épidémie
est ce que vous connaissez un autre pays
dans le monde dans lequel on est autant
soutenu les salariés les entreprises les
gens qui sont au chômage
les intermittents du spectacle on a on a
investi ou dépenser des sommes
considérables pour maintenir l'unité du
pays at-elle et ça n'était pas facile et
on peut pas dire que ils s'en sont lavés
les mains et franchement aujourd'hui
tout le monde tout le monde le reconnaît
et déjà pas si mal eux avoir été
salariée en france ça n'avait rien à
voir avec le salarié ailleurs où on
n'avait pas du tout les mêmes droits
sauf que tout ça ça évidemment creuser
le déficit creusé la dette vous en 2007
alors que vous étiez candidat à la
présidentielle vous faisiez de la
question de la dette une question
cruciale je les cite la réalité du
déficit et de la dette qui est en train
d'écraser les générations les plus
jeunes qui sont là d'une manière
irresponsable scandaleuse et immoral ça
c'était en 2007 depuis ça n'a fait
qu'empirer et vous dites je n'ai pas
changé d'avis et peut-être vous
vérifierez ainsi qui m'arrive d'avoir
raison avant bien d'autres
et après tout je revendique sa mais
cette dette là j'ai comme vous savez
avec le plan consacré une note de
perspectives de prospective à cette date
là cette date là elle n'est pas une
dette comme les autres c'est une dette
de guerre nous n'avons pas eu le choix
ça veut dire que cette dette il faut
l'échelonner il faut la proposition que
j'ai faite il faut considérer que
pendant 10 ans on va faire un différé
d'amortissement on le fait bien quand on
achète une maison on fait un différé
d'impôts en appartement on peut faire un
différé d'amortissement et dans dix ans
on en reprendra le remboursement en
l'étalant suffisamment pour que l'on
puisse le supporter pourquoi peut-on le
faire parce que comme vous savez
l'argent aujourd'hui est extrêmement peu
cher mais j'ai ajouté une deuxième chose
faut pas s'arrêter là
il faut un plan marshall pour
reconquérir la production du pays
conditions industrielles
il faut les empreintes et la production
industrielle
la production agricole les services on
peut pas supporter les déséquilibres
dans lesquelles nous sommes enfermés
depuis si longtemps et qui font que vous
rendez compte la france déséquilibre
commercial de la france c'est quelque
chose comme 70 ou 75 milliards d'euros
par an et les allemands c'est 250
milliards d'excédents seulement sont pas
beaucoup plus intelligent ni beaucoup
moins j'espère pas une différence
d'intelligence ses peines c'est une
différence de d'organisation et de
volonté du pays et donc on a à
reconstruire à partir à la reconquête et
j'ai pas d'autres certitudes que celle
là la bataille n'est pas perdue encore
faut-il la livre et ça fait 30 ans qu'on
va livre pas livrer la bataille sur la
réindustrialisation du pays se relancer
le pays là encore il va y avoir besoin
d'une sorte de pacte peut-être le
renouveler on a bien compris qu'il ne
s'était jamais rompu il sait jamais
rompu entre les deux hommes que vous
êtes
emmanuel macron vous même mais il est
quand même très distendus entre vos
équipes
j'en veux pour preuve cette tribune
c'est le magazine loeb ce qu'il révèle
cette tribune qui devait être signé par
les parlementaires la république en
marche
à j
et modem sur une idée de stéphane ces
journées qui est conseiller politique du
président visiblement il semble que vos
troupes n'ont pas accepté de ratifier ce
texte
officiellement dit que c'est une
question de timing
mais patrick mignola qui est quand même
le patron des bleus a été menée lé 10 7
c'est une bague cette question timing
la vérité c'est qu'ils disent est
tribunal verser dans l'autosatisfaction
c'est pas une maison près de l'année
s'était pas vraiment une mais à chacun
son style
et moi quand on m'amène une tribune déjà
écrite en me demandant simplement de la
signer je n'ai de ma vie jamais signé
une tribune que je n'ai pas écrite et
surtout vous voyez bien que des
parlementaires signe des tribunes pour
expliquer que leur président est un
grand homme et que jamais il ya eu deux
des actions politiques aussi brillante
c'est pas notre style parce que c'est
difficile à faire comprendre surtout à
des gens qui sont sympathiques et bien
intentionnés quand vous allez devant le
pays en disant regardez comme en
champions est formidable forcément ce
que vous vous attirez c'est un peu
d'ironie ou en tout cas un peu de
réticence
c'est pas comme ça pour moi qu'on fait
de la politique je vous écoute bien en
fait quand on a eu des députés la public
en marge qui disait nous avons une
pensée trop complexe nous sommes trop
intelligent en fait c'est un peu c'est
un peu là dedans qui tombe là nouveau
quoi vous voyez bien il ya des des
approches différentes des ce n'était
malheureusement même temps vous vous
n'hésitez pas à dire qu'il est
formidable mais vous ne voulez pas mais
je fais pas scier des tribunes pour le
dire je pense que plus on parle de
manière authentique personnel et sincère
- on passe par les moules habituels de
la politique et mieux c'est parce qu'on
est davantage crédible au final ce genre
de tribunes qui pourrait être une
tribune commune
vos députés et c'est pas une usine
commune qu'il faut c'est des actions
communes
c'est pas des c'est pas des
protestations publiques avec des
tambours et des trompettes et des
violents mais précisé c'est pas comme ça
qu'il faut c'est la question est ce que
vous vous êtes pas faire peut avoir
c'est à dire est ce que le moddeur ma
leçon quand je je vois que je vois que
vous voudriez me le faire dit mais je ne
peux pas vous dire oui parce que je ne
le pense pas alors je je vais aller
encore un peu plus loin la vème
république c'est pas un marchandage
ceux qui croient que c'est des rapports
de force dans lesquelles l'un va obliger
l'autre ils ont rien compris à la vème
république la vème république c'est une
adhésion
vous avez quelqu'un qui est élu à
l'élection de chivu participer et après
vous êtes dans un rapport de confiance
pas dans un rapport d'épreuve de force
il n'y a pas ce qui tordent le bras et
les autres en aucune manière la vème
république c'est sa part de la basse et
pas d'un sommet qui voudraient imposer
sa vie en tout cas c'était ma vision
mais bon c'est la vision des choses que
vous n'avez pas obtenu une avance ainsi
que nous n'avons pas obtenu pour
l'instant et comme je vous ai dit je
n'ai jamais pensé que les batailles
était fini vous n'avez donc pas renoncé
et peut-être que le second quinquennat
sera le bon s'il est réélu bon on verra
il ya eu des difficultés quand même qui
ont jalonné ce ces quatre années passées
françois bayrou des difficultés
personnelles on va y revenir la
souffrance d'avoir perdu une de vos très
proche marielle de sarnez
il ya eu des difficultés aussi juridique
judiciaire
vous deviez être l'homme de la justice
aujourd'hui on le voit bien la justice
allait très mal vu par une grande partie
des français or le garde des sceaux
ç'aurait dû être pourquoi ça s'est
arrêté parce que il ya eu cette enquête
cette enquête sur la question du
dévoiement des financements l'union
européenne qui au lieu d'être utilisés
pour des gens qui travaillent est
véritablement pour l'europe et pour le
parlement européen aurait été utilisée
au profit du parti le modem le journal
le monde
elle cette semaine que l'anc est à
étaler jusqu au bout et que et bien
l'information judiciaire et les
enquêteurs ont mis à jour je les cite un
système ancien et plus ou moins
informelle visant à utiliser les fonds
du parlement européen afin de permettre
le maintien de l'activité du parti et le
niveau de rémunération des salariés de
l'udf modem
qu'est ce que vous répondez je réponds
une chose simple
ce n'est pas vrai regardez dans les yeux
ce n'est pas vrai et le jour où on
voudra s'intéresser aux preuves
on verra on constatera que ce n'est pas
vrai d'ailleurs j'ai il se trouve que
j'ai lu ce rapport et il me semble que
ça progresse un peu parce que toutes les
phrases que que l'on dit qu'il dit un
système aléatoire informel et on peut
pas quantifier
ça veut dire qu' il n'y a pas d'éléments
probants tomber et soupes seront ils
sont infondées et le jour il faudra tas
sera prouvée et donc c'est la première
chose deuxième chose c'est que ces
accusations la haye ce qu'elle reproche
est-ce qu'elle repose sur quoi que ce
soit de répréhensible moralement pape
seulement pour nous mais pour les
formations politiques
le front national il ya les insoumis qui
sont c'est pas si sensible c'est pas que
c'est pas si grave
un parlementaire c'est quelqu'un qui vit
au piège élu grâce un parti politique
gratte pas politique
le fait de tracts avec son talent
politique